congratulations on being here on this
quick question for you would you say
that you're writing more now than you
were when you first began whoo well you
know one thing I have discovered is that
it doesn't get any easier and I'm much
more aware of my mortality these days so
I'm typing as fast as I can that's
that's really my way of responding that
I'm trying I'm trying to continue an
output so for a writer that wants to
make a switch in their life mid-career
let's suppose they're doing something
else how would you advise that they
balance writing with a nine-to-five job
and it could be in the industry maybe
not only industry you know I think the
crucial thing is to find a group of
people even if even if you are at a
nine-to-five job you know either
weekends or nights fine to find a group
of like-minded people and gather
together and hear each other's work
because there's nothing more lonely than
working in isolation I think it's really
important to be with people who
stimulate you last question why is
storytelling important to you
storytelling is important because I
think it's part of our our tradition as
humans you know humans have always
craved stories they've always they've
always embraced a folklore and myth and
oral history and I think it's just I
think it's just part of being human